if there was stats available for every  aspect of your life  what one stat would you want to see how  many times  i've given myself a butt rash by just  scratching my ass  my own act like helmet dude all the time  dude  all the time like i'll just scratch  through the underwear  like and i only give it to the left  cheek for whatever reason i don't  scratch right cheek but left hand  right cheek i kind of scratch from hole  to up on the cheek and i want to know  how many times i've given my own self  chafing how many  times i chafe myself that's the stat  that i want to know could you  give me a ball a thousand thousand  minimum dude thousand  minimum okay i'm working on some like  light scabbing now i gotta let that come  down the second it comes down we're  going raw  rip it wrong